for the royals daniel lynch will make
his second start of his big league
career
there's a ground ball into right that's
a leadoff single for tim anderson
oh two base hit they're two for two with
two strikes
anderson's going to hold it second
so now the white sox are cooking with
gas jawan monkatta steps to the plate
first and second nobody out
and the old one is hooked down the left
field line that is a fair ball
here comes anderson madrigal trying to
score
it is two nothing three batters in
first and third now with one out yasmani
grand all comes to the plate
the contact here deep to center
monkatta will tag from third
dyson with the catch it's three-nothing
on a sac fly
mercedes at first two outs in the batter
andrew vaughn
golfed high in the air well hit to left
ben and tendy at the wall he can't make
the play a runt's going to score
mercedes to the dish
it's four nothing
boy for a second there i thought andrew
had his first home run
as it is
it's an rbi double a four-nothing lead
here's the eight-hitter
garcia
[Applause]
fly ball to right in the corner
that is a fair ball
vaughn's going to score
leoria on his way to third
it's a triple danny mendick so all nine
coming to the plate here in the first
[Applause]
2-2 pitch
in the left
deep and gone danny mendick with a home
run
boy you talk about not letting a guy off
the hook
that was a two-strike home run
for danny mendick
as the ninth batter of a seven-run first
inning
a single for tim anderson a single for
nick madrigal a double for johann
mancott jose a bray you walked you mean
mercedes with a fielder's choice gives
money grandall with a sacrifice fly
vaughn doubled garcia tripled and danny
mendick the nine hitter tonight
with a home run to left tim anderson
bats for the second time in the first
sox up seven nothing
and into right anderson on again
[Applause]
that may go as an error against santana
over at first it looked like lynch
thought he was going to get himself and
out
mike matheny might yeah he's going to
have to go pull the trigger here
and make a change this bullpen we may
see position player pitching theater
tonight if it stays like this
so lynch cannot get through the first
tyler zuber right-hander
is coming on and looks like lynch's
head's spinning right now
[Applause]
round ball into right
nick is two for two
both on two strike hits
joanne moncada up for the second time
first and second two out socks up seven
nothing
monkatta with a two-run double
right-handed
and there's a base hit to center
anderson coming home
eight nothing
first and second for jose ground ball to
the second baseman
field and that is the end of the top of
the first
lancelin looking for win number three
oh one home he's hit in the air
and mendic
a long run over and his first chance he
handles no problem so you want to play
right field danny go run a lot
eight nothing after one
he struck him out
strike three ran to the corner
[Applause]
one two comes home swing and a miss lin
gets another strikeout victim i would
doubt he's looking for an extra 90 feet
here down eight nothing stranger things
have happened here's the o2 swing and a
miss lynne gets it
strikes out the side
three two coming
[Applause]
high fastball flick to first
abreu
beginning over
eight nothing socks after four in kansas
city
now leori garcia
and he goes after the first pitch pops
it up into shallow right
and it's merrifield with a nice
over-the-shoulder catch
you hear silence if you're an infielder
it's yours all the way oh man that was
airfield singled in the third
swing and a miss strike three
he busts that one well deep to center
that's a way back
and it's off the top of the wall
the best that santana could do
was make it to third base
the guys who run the fireworks thought
it was gone
but
it was a double for jorge soler
kick in the old one
this is going to get kopeck out of it
garcia makes the grabba strand two eight
nothing jason's big fireworks story is
jack's oversell
but dyson gets him with a shot to the
alley in right center and gerard likely
is going to go for three
but his speed
will make it standing up
airfield one for three
[Applause]
two third
and the royals streak is over at 28
consecutive innings without a run dyson
scores
as merefield grounds
[Music]
abreu powders one and it'll get off the
wall
hustling towards second he's got a
sliding
double davis home on an 02 pounded on
the ground into left de bruyne will come
around and score
there's the salvage for your mean
little two out rally here in the ninth
it's nine to one
anderson will get it to madrigal
two
game over
and the white sox have a chance for a
series sweep tomorrow